hey youtubers it's Charlie so arrow and
the flash have continued to make a lot
of casting announcements in the last
couple of weeks so I wanted to do a
villains power ranking this will just be
for arrow season 3 I'm gonna do a
separate video for the flash eventually
and I'll do a hero power ranking to the
news fill in is comodo he's gonna be
played by Matt Ward you might remember
him from Tron Legacy he was cast as
Simon Lacroix but in the comics Lacroix
is Komodo that's why we say Matt Ward is
Komodo think of it in terms of Batman
his real mask you know his alter-ego is
Bruce Wayne inside he's really that Dark
Knight character arrow season 3 is gonna
refer to most of these villains by their
real-life personas with the exception of
Ra's al Ghul
he has no alter-ego unless you want to
consider the demons head and his
alter-ego he's really the same person no
matter who he's talking to though
there's no secret identity
this power ranking is gonna start off
with the least powerful two most
powerful beginning with Manhunter this
is the mark sha Manhunter not Martian
Manhunter the one who's associated with
Suicide Squad in the comics he's gonna
be part of a Diggle Amanda Waller story
so I'm guessing he's not a flashback
character remember some of the people
that they've cast are only going to
appear in the Hong Kong flashbacks and
some will only appear in present day but
there are a couple that will crossover I
know it gets a little confusing if you
read the comics because the current
Manhunter is Kate Spencer which actually
gives me some interesting theories about
what they're gonna do with Laurel this
season mark shadow was originally a
public defender who was trained by a
secret society called the Manhunters he
joined so that he'd be able to fight
crime in a more effective way like Frank
Castle becoming the Punisher and just
like the Punisher Shaw eventually went a
little bit nuts and started to go over
the line like way over the line which is
pretty much why I put him on the list
you know even if he's neutral or just a
little bit bad he's gonna be on the bad
list it's a really interesting point you
know yes you can be a villain even if
you're not trying to be evil think of
Shaw as more of a character that
wandered off the path at least in the
comics which is probably how arrow is
going to treat him usually doing
something like that will land you in an
Argus prison on the show he's gonna be
going up against Diggle in the Suicide
Squad episode in the new 52 comics the
big reboot Shaw is a u.s. marshal still
questionable morality so I'm kind of
curious to see if arrow does a
mix-and-match thing where they give
Laurel some of the aspects like that
Kate Spencer Manhunter blended with
Shaw's hunter in the old comics like I
don't
that Shah is gonna wear Manhunter
costume but I am curious to see if they
give Laurel some of his traits think
about it this way Laurel works in the
DA's office she's gonna be training to
fight this season either with Wildcat or
Oliver probably both though what if they
have an episode where she tries to
dispense her own kind of personal
justice kind of combining the original
mark Shaw Manhunter with the Kate
Spencer Manhunter remember Kate Spencer
was also a federal prosecutor in the
comics which is kind of close to what
Laurel does I'm not expecting to happen
and I don't think Laurel is gonna be
wearing any kind of costumes and
obviously we all want her to become
Black Canary at some point but keep your
eyes peeled for Laurel kicking butt in a
non Black Canary way so increasing the
threat level just a little next is Thea
queen I'm not gonna call her straight-up
Artemis but I think the show is pushing
her in that direction I know a lot of
you guys want her to be Lady Shiva but
think more of Artemis in Young Justice
you know only is more of an antagonist
to team arrow like Willa Hans gonna be a
crankier version of Artemis she and
Colton Haynes actually posted this
picture from the set you could see that
new short haircut that she's sporting
and she also posted pictures from her
training in the gym the show is still
pairing her off with Roy like she'll get
scenes with Roy but technically she's on
Team Berlin which makes her a villain I
know a lot of you might not be totally
convinced that Thea could ever be a
threat to Roy but remember Thea was a
champion Archer and Merlyn has the
wisdom of the League of Assassins think
of it in terms of training ability I
think that Merlyn will be a better
trainer to Thea than Oliver will be to
Roy I know that might sound
controversial Merlyn was trained by Ra's
al Ghul who I think is more powerful
than Slade yes Oliver did get some good
training from Slade so I don't
necessarily think that Merlyn is a way
better fighter than him I just think
that he's a better teacher than he is
like even as high as Oliver's writing
he's still not quite at that level of
maturity as he is whenever he joins
Justice League but some of the most fun
this season that I'm looking forward to
is watching Merlyn train Thea and
watching Oliver train Roy it's gonna be
so much fun especially whenever Thea
goes up against Roy and starts kicking
his butt climbing up the ladder a little
further we have Deadshot Michael Roe is
returning in a Suicide Squad episode I'm
expecting to see him more than once
there's gonna be at least one special
dedicated Suicide Squad episode but they
sometimes get cameos in other episodes
like smaller stories also I didn't put
her on the
just because it's not confirmed but
supposedly Harlequin will have a full-on
cameo in season 3 obviously as part of
his Suicide Squad episode like a cameo
that actually makes it to air
whenever Cassidy Alexa did her last
season they had that super short teaser
in the Suicide Squad episode and then
another cameo that she was in in the
finale but both those got left on the
cutting room floor like they were cut
out at the last minute before the
episodes aired before they started
filming Stephen Amell made it pretty
clear that he thought that Harlequin was
a really cool idea for the show and yes
you know he doesn't call the shots but
don't be surprised if you see Harley
Quinn in an actual episode but moving
along just above Deadshot I put Komodo
he was a huge Green Arrow villain in the
new 52 comics he's connected to Oliver's
father and he even worked inside Queen
industries I don't know how the show's
gonna change him from the comics but he
could potentially show up in flashbacks
and in present day like in the comics he
had a beef against Oliver but he's also
connected to count vertigo so when we do
see him in the present day he'll
probably have something to do with count
vertigo Splott there was a story from
the comics where he kidnapped shadow's
daughter and helped vertigo so he might
end up kidnapping or trying to kidnap
Felicity or Laurel since Laurel is
supposedly gonna be in training the
season either with Wildcat or Oliver
it'd be nice to see her actually go up
against Komodo or take him down that'd
be a really awesome moment for her they
would have to depower him just a little
since his comic book version is supposed
to be just as formidable as Oliver and I
don't think that Laurel is gonna be as
good as Oliver this season like she's
not gonna get that good that fast so now
we're starting to move up into like the
supervillain stratosphere so next is
Talia al Ghul she's coming back with
Ra's al Ghul League of Assassins stories
or episodes that feature the league at
least Black Canary is only back for
three episodes this season so I'm
expecting Talia to show up in one of
those in terms of fighting ability I
rank her like just below Oliver just
because she was able to fight him to a
standstill in hand-to-hand combat and
with a bow and arrow still Oliver is way
stronger just from his sheer size some
of these upper level characters are
better than each other under certain
conditions like each of them has their
own specialties Talia is way more
vicious than Oliver and Merlyn for
instance but both of them are stronger
so a lot of times it just depends on
what the conditions of the fight are so
moving up to number 3 Amanda Waller yes
I am considering her a villain for this
season
she's neutral really but the way arrow
uses her is mostly as an antagonist she
really only helps team arrow when she's
forced to or when it suits her remember
even if you're just a little bit evil
you can be considered a villain villains
can still totally do good things and
continued to be villains just like
Merlin I'm expecting Waller to give off
like a really evil vibe in the
flashbacks
she's clearly keeping Oliver there
against his wishes forcing him to help
her I know everyone's wondering how he
ended up back on the island in the pilot
especially with that giant beard it
supposedly came after Hong Kong probably
because he and Waller had a falling-out
I'm hoping that the flashbacks this
season explained their relationship a
little bit better
so up to number two now Malcolm Merlyn
who is nothing like John Barrowman in
real life Stephen Amell said that the
biggest prankster on the arrow set is
John Barrowman
I love the idea that Malcolm Merlyn is
like the consummate prankster like he's
the Tom Hiddleston Loki of the series so
he gets to be bad and good I think that
Merlyn is a neutral figure but I think
he swings chaotic neutral or lawful
neutral depending on the situation like
when he's training Thea he'll be lawful
neutral and when he's trying to confound
team arrow he'll be chaotic neutral I'm
also kind of wondering if Merlin's gonna
try and play team arrow against Ra's al
Ghul like use them as a distraction or
better yet use team arrow as a human
shield against the League of Assassins
remember Merlyn is on Ra's al Ghul's
list so it's totally possible that
Oliver Merlyn could continue to be
villains throughout the entire season
but at some point Oliver could wind up
fighting with Merlyn against Ra's al
Ghul Stephen Amell has said that Oliver
and Merlyn will always have unfinished
business you know mostly referring to
Tommy in the Earthshaker but Ra's al
Ghul is like the one thing that could
put that fight on hold so let me know
big questions number one do you want to
see Oliver in Merlyn get like a big
Throwdown and number two do you want to
see them fight together against Ra's al
Ghul which of course leads me to my most
powerful villain this season the demons
head my big question with him is is what
is so compelling that he will leave
Nanda Parbat to go to Starling think
about it this way usually what you see
is by the end of the season all the
villains stories tied together so Ra's
al Ghul will be in Starling because of
something black Canary does something
Merlyn does and something that vertigo
does that doesn't include any
interaction between Ray Palmer story or
any of the other heroes coming to the
show but
try and address that whenever I do my
hero Power Rankings ideally what you
want to see by the end of the season is
is like all the new characters have some
sort of connection in some way like all
the different stories all tied together
those like a focal point but be sure to
subscribe to get that video I'll try and
post it next week quick update on Friday
and Saturday videos too there's lots of
stuff happening Legend of Korra season
finale will be streaming on Nickelodeon
tomorrow for free so be sure to watch it
I'll post my video afterwards and Doctor
Who series 8 episode 1 on Saturday so
lots of big videos I probably will not
sleep but it's gonna be a lot of fun
also be live-tweeting a lot of stuff so
if you want to follow me on Twitter it's
awesome emergency and on Facebook it's
just you know slash Facebook but in the
meantime but you guys are getting ready
click here to learn all about Justice
League dart and click here to get my big
Marvel Avengers phase 3 Q&A thank you so
much for watching I'll see you guys
tomorrow high fives
you